two of the four Americans who were
kidnapped last Friday in the Mexican
state of damaulipas are dead
the news was confirmed early on Tuesday
by the governor of Tamaulipas during a
phone call with Mexico's president
Andres Manuel Lopez
and it was fully confirmed by the
prosecutor's office two of the four are
dead one is injured and the other is
alive
the two survivors of the attack have
since been transferred back across the
border into Texas
State officials in Mexico say Mexican
Security Forces had been working in
close collaboration with U.S FBI and DEA
agents and that at least one of the
alleged kidnappers has been detained
there will be by national cooperation to
continue in this investigation the four
Americans crossed into Mexico last
Friday reportedly on a medical tourism
trip as cost for medical procedures in
Mexico are much lower than in the U.S
according to local reports shortly after
entering Mexico their vehicle a white
minivan was shot at by gunmen
this footage appears to show the moment
the four passengers on board were taken
away setting off an international
incident today we learned the very sad
news that Mexican state and federal
authorities were covered four U.S
citizens kidnapped on March 3rd in
Matamoras Mexico two U.S citizens will
return to the United States the bodies
of two other U.S citizens killed in the
same incident were also recovered
we're providing all appropriate
assistance to them and their families we
extend our deepest condolences all four
Americans were found in the village of
tecolte about 24 kilometers from the
border city of Matamoros where the
kidnapping took place
this area is known for being home to
warring factions of the gulf cartel
Mexico stema Lipa state is also among
half a dozen Mexican states that were
recently named on a do not travel list
by the U.S state Department Manuel
rapalo Al Jazeera
[Music]